[Music]
mia joins us from sacramento california
mia welcome to the ramsay show
hi hillman um my question today is two
parts but the first part is um i have
paid off all my debt except one debt um
about five thousand dollars thank you
um and um
i just
so it was five thousand so i had to save
for that amount of money
so what i did was i saved and i just
kept saving so i saved 20 000
so um but i just can't pull the trigger
and pay it off i i just i don't know so
it's like you were running a marathon
and you went past the finish line and
you're like i'm just going to keep going
no it's not i don't think it's out no
you got to the sign that says yeah you
got to decide mia that said last mile
and everyone starts cheering and you
just
cracked open a beer and sat down and
you're like i'm good it's going to sit
here for a while
yeah so i'm like stuck in step two if i
do this i'll be in step four because
it's 20 000
so you already saved your
my emergency fund okay so tell us about
this debt yeah what is it beautiful is
it cute
is it sentimental do you love it
no it's a repossession of a car that
happened 2017
um and
i'm just like and it's that look it's
with an attorney now
um because there's a judgment against me
i don't know if i'm scared to call the
attorney like i have the number i dialed
the number and i hung up
i won't because it's a voicemail it goes
straightly to a voicemail
um and you're supposed to leave your
number do you have a judge do you have a
judgment payoff letter in your hand
um yeah i have the court documents where
it was the judge
granted the um
you know the order for me to pay and
this was in 2017.
um
are you afraid that that bill has
tripled or quadrupled on you because you
haven't paid it
well it started off at 2300 so i'm
guesstimating it's about five right now
so you don't even know i added the entry
so you're in la la you got your hands
over your ears going i don't wanna know
i don't wanna know exactly
yeah well i'm thinking it's about i've
done the math so it's about between five
and six thousand dollars and you hope
you hope so mia what do you do for a
living
i'm a government worker for the state
that's another part of my question but
okay so how much about 67. how much data
how much debt have you paid off
um olaf paid off
22 000
but all of it was smaller it was credit
card debt
are you are you you sound like you are
brilliant are you smart
i i'm yeah i'm just saying yeah
are you like are you a hard worker
very hard worker are you a person of
integrity and character
yes very important to me would you would
you date somebody that was like you
absolutely yeah
so you're checking every box you're
brilliant you're smart you're a hard
worker you're a person of character
and yet
i just love my debt
you have marked every box
you are the kind of person we want out
in our communities we want this kind of
people out there leading things right
and so here's what i want you to do i
want you to trust mia as much as we do
i want you to think of mia as highly as
we do
mia you are worthy of being
free
you have solved for freedom
and the last thing is that last little
chain link is in those hedge clippers
and you just gotta
pull them
okay okay just gotta do it what why are
you scared of freedom
i'm just thinking and i think about
because i listen to you i think i might
be catastrophizing like i'm like what if
i lose my job and i'll go wrong in this
20 000 i got rid of five and and then
you know how i'm gonna take care of me
and my son and then you know it could
all fall down and and i gave him five
thousand when i could have really held
on to it oh well
or or or you have 15 000 in your fully
funded emergency fund you have no
lawyers breathing down your neck no
ticker running in the background that's
adding up more interest and more
interest to more interest and then you
are free
you're
free and you're a hard worker you'll
have 5000 more dollars in a couple more
months right
yeah and then you and your son can do
whatever you want to like hey what's
your what's your favorite food mia
uh thai food here's what i want you to
do i want you to make that call today as
soon as you're off the line and keep
calling until someone picks up and i
want you to get this debt out of your
life this week and i want you to go get
some thai food with your kid and have
the night of your life celebrating the
fact that you don't have payments
anymore
how great would that feel okay
that would be awesome like i really so
can i ask you guys i want to ask the
second question really quick come on um
i'm 43 i have about 4k i just started
retirement
and
um i want to know is it possible hope
for me to have a home i have a really
affordable rent right now but i've told
myself either it's a home or it's
retirement because i've waited so late
to start building my retirement never
too late you're so young you said 43
honey you're just getting started you
are just getting started
never too late you can do both of these
things and at this rate with no payments
in the world and your income which is
only going to go up because you're
brilliant you can do both you can get in
a house and our parameters just so you
know i want you to put i think you can
put 20 or more down you can do this with
a 15-year fixed rate mortgage to where
this thing's gone before you retire and
i guarantee you're going to do it
earlier because you hustle
and i want you to do it to where the
payment is no more than a quarter of
your take-home pay
and you're going to invest 15
into retirement accounts and in 25 years
you're going to be a multi-millionaire
with a paid for house
now buying a house in sacramento that
may be a taller order than buying one in
st louis missouri right and so yeah you
may be staring at the local sacramento
housing prizes and thinking
i might not be able to do this and it
may be that down the road you think i
may take my
brilliance and my character and my hard
work and my debt-free life to another
state to another city um that's all very
real right so somebody's going to be
dependent on cost of living where you're
living right but don't box yourself into
don't become free and then box yourself
into unfree thinking
i'm free
no i'm just back to the no
you got nobody chasing you anymore and
now it's a matter of where do i want to
be what kind of life do i want to build
i would love to live here but i can't
own a home here so i'm going to move
there right or i would love to keep
working here but i can make double the
salary over here now you are
it's a great reminder in addition to
going to thai food i want you to look
yourself in the mirror
the day after you pay this thing off and
remind yourself
i'm brilliant i'm a hard worker i'm a
person of character and i deserve
freedom and now sky's the limit because
i have unhooked the last chain
around my
neck i'm free i'm inspired john you can
take back control you can do it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]